[Aplausos]
sigue desafiante incluso tras una
sentencia que podría prohibirle volver
la política el alcalde de Estambul le
cree mi mamu Blue se dirigió a una
multitud de sus seguidores que salieron
en masa en la capital de Turquía dijo
que su condena por un tribunal Turco por
insultar a funcionarios públicos era el
resultado de maniobras políticas
esta decisión ha demostrado que no queda
justicia en Turquía
[Música]
este proceso judicial está dirigido por
personas que no quieren llevar al país
valores como la justicia y la democracia
su Victoria en las elecciones a la
alcaldía de 2019 fue anulada
inicialmente tras las denuncias del
partido gobernante en la Cape de
irregularidades en la votación tras unas
nuevas elecciones ordenadas por la
comisión electoral obtuvo una ajustada
Victoria que puso fin a 25 años de
gobierno de la capella en la ciudad ha
declarado que recorrirá su reciente
condenada a sus 52 años se le considera
el político de la oposición más fuerte
para enfrentarse al presidente erdoan en
las elecciones que se celebrarán en
junio de 2023 el país se enfrenta
actualmente una serie de problemas
económicos entre ellos una elevada
inflación Aún está por verse sí Malú
estará en la papeleta
[Aplausos]